and for the first time we're hearing
from the family of a man who was shot
and killed by police this all happened a
month ago right near nellis in vegas
valley police were there serving a
search warrant and once inside they were
met by gunfire but the family tells 8
news now is victoria saha it was all
self-defense and she joins us from the
newsroom with this exclusive interview
isaiah williams was 19 when he was
killed last month in a shootout with
metro police his mom is still heavily
grieving but wants answers from metro
because she says her son did not deserve
to die
this body cam footage released by police
shows the moments before officers kicked
down the door to serve their search
warrant and met by gunfire from isaiah
williams
his mom latia alexander is still trying
to comprehend the situation for the
moment of me watching the video
i just
froze up i was shaking so bad police
were issuing a search warrant for a
suspect connected to a murder that
happened back in november police say
williams fired 18 times at officers and
between five of them 23 rounds were
fired back at williams body cam footage
shows williams was laying on the couch
with a gun right by the door do you
believe that he didn't hear police the
police saying their presence i honestly
believe that he did not hear it his mom
says williams was a heavy sleeper and
missed curfew that night and slept at
his friend's apartment uncomfortable in
a new environment he slept with a gun by
his side he was scared for sure she says
he was not connected to the suspect
police were looking for and the suspect
did not live there no we weren't in the
wrong address angered by the intensity
of the situation his family demanded
answers by protesting at a police forum
thursday evening they did not deserve to
die his mom wants everyone to know the
body cam footage does not define who her
son was for years old like the older the
elderly if he see him take the garbage
he'll go grab the garbage take the
garbage out
police did admit williams was not the
person they were looking for the right
suspect was arrested a few days after
that incident two officers were shot but
one officer still has a long road to
recovery as for williams's mom she's
still waiting for police documents and
the coroner's report so she can pay to
lay her son to rest brian